i felt
rather betrayed i felt uh
anxious for
the next generation of of women
weightlifters
because what are they going to face if
we keep going down the trail that we are
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people it doesn't get any more
fascinating than the guest we have for
you today she is a pioneer of women's
weightlifting a former national champion
and america referee and also an author
and writer as well judy glenny welcome
to trigonometry thank you it's a
pleasure to be with you
it's so great that you could join us
today it's obviously a time in which
women's weightlifting and some of the
other issues that you've written about
in the past is very much in the public
eye before we get into all of that uh
please tell us and our audience a bit
more about your background who are you
what is your journey through life how do
you find yourself sitting here talking
to us all the way across the pond my
background is primarily in sports i
participated in sports all through my
growing up years but then i met this
wonderful man who later became my
husband who was a weightlifter
and i became absolutely fascinated with
the sport of weightlifting the type that
you see in the olympics where you put
the weight over your head
well there was no weightlifting for
women at that time when i started
training and started working with him
but we decided that
i enjoyed it so much why not start the
sport for women so that's that began my
journey in weightlifting at that time
like i mentioned there was no
official entry for women so i competed
against the men well i shouldn't say i
competed against them i competed
alongside of them i wasn't allowed to
compete within the competition
so i was competing outside the
competition just because i enjoyed this
sport and i wanted to do the best that i
could
so as the years uh came by i
wanted to um really involve other women
because i knew i wasn't the only crazy
out there that wanted to do this so by
and large i started
getting in contact with other women
other officials we had our first uh
national competition in 1981.
that grew into involving more countries
as i became more aware and more
connected with the international
weightlifting community so we had our
first
world championship in 1987 but my dream
had always been to get weightlifting
into the olympics
so i
i just made so many more contacts
which led me to uh thinking that this
might be a possibility so long story
short we did get the the
women's weightlifting into the olympics
in 2000 which was amazing
i had the opportunity to by that time my
my what lifting career uh
on the platform had long since been uh
gone
but i did have the opportunity to
uh be an official at that
olympics i was just so pleased to see
these women on the platform
during this time i also was dealing with
uh or shortly after this time i should
say i started dealing with my son who
announced that he was transgender
so i have this background in my family
dealing with this issue now that has
entered the weightlifting arena so that
is
my background and that is the subject of
your second book uh dealing with with
your son and and that story um so let
let's talk it first of all about the the
weightlifting part of it i imagine that
when you were doing this in the 70s and
and the 80s and later
you were not exactly being embraced by
by the many of the men who were
competing in weightlifting i imagine it
would not have been easy am i right
oh no no
oh yes there were many raised eyebrows
many words exchanged uh fortunately my
husband
uh
was kind of a buffer but
as i would be in these competitions and
would say want to warm up on the
platform before my lips oh my goodness
the the comments what is she doing here
she has no right being here and they
would scorn and they would
essentially give me the impression that
i was totally invading their sacred
space
[Music]
but
the
meat directors
would allow me again to compete they
said no you cannot compete within the
competition but you can certainly
compete outside the competition so it
took a long time
before we could convince the
weightlifting community that women could
do this
and that's one of the things i might add
that i really wanted to
to get across to the public as the women
started to compete that these were women
who really appreciated the sport
they were
uh knowledgeable about the sport they
could do the technique and we were
athletes first we weren't out there to
uh
burst the the as it were the ceiling of
men's weightlifting but we just wanted
to compete as athletes
and you say you just wanted to compete
as athletes you must have had such a
tremendous sense of pride you know to
take
a sport that was very much at the
margins and then bring it into the
mainstream with the olympics
oh i was just i i was i was on the jury
at the olympic games and
i just sat there with with such emotion
that these women
to use the expression did me proud
they were such
technicians they
they
carried themselves like women they
carried themselves like athletes and i
couldn't have been more proud of the way
they convicted themselves and their
performances they lifted fantastic so i
was
i was like a mother hand as it were
so and this is kind of what what i think
we're getting at the the process of
getting women the opportunity to compete
on a par with men in the olympics is
something that you and other people like
you had to fight for for a period of
time which brings us on to the
conversation that is being had now about
this issue where
uh you know depending on how you see it
uh some people would argue that that
opportunity is now being taken away from
women uh with someone like laurel
hubbard coming in uh what is your take
on that whole situation
i have a lot of takes on that whole
situation we got an hour judy so you go
for it
um
first of all um
i i believe that
with your comment about our getting into
women's sports
we did fight so hard for for women uh
not only in weightlifting but in other
sports
to compete on an equal playing field we
we tried very hard to get access to
coaches to
facilities to equipment that would just
allow us as women to compete in
something that we truly did enjoy
so
when these opportunities came about we
embraced them
and we competed against women
and i think that that was the main thing
that that i wanted i didn't want to
compete against the men i wanted to
compete against women
that's where my heart was
that's where i felt i could contribute
most was to give the opportunity to
women who enjoyed what i did
i knew as i put before i wasn't the only
crazy and as i found out i wasn't
there's a whole world of women out there
that really did enjoy weightlifting so i
wanted to give them the opportunity to
compete on that equal footing women
against women
and it came about not only in
weightlifting but in in the other sports
as well
so when we are addressing this whole
transgender issue i that that that
comes on
several levels
when i first saw that she was going to
compete uh a lot of emotions uh
frustration
uh a little bit of anger
but
the the sense that that my work and not
only mine but so many other women who
have and i might add that i didn't
pioneer this on my own i had so much
help and so uh i'm i'm just kind of the
the face of weightlifting at this point
but by
so many other women were involved in
getting this to to get the women's into
the olympics
so when it came to
this issue
um
i felt
rather betrayed i felt
anxious for the next generation of of
women weightlifters
because what are they going to face if
we keep going down the trail that we are
so for example
uh
the and we're talking about the ioc the
international olympic committee
has changed their policy through the
years and this is what really concerns
me about where this is going with with
this whole uh agenda
that first of all when we first started
competing internationally and we made
the women kind of made a joke about this
we had gender testing that was we sobbed
the the cheat and and there were actual
chromosome testing
and
we kind of joked that we had a little
card that said we were a genuine female
that's not such a joke anymore
so
that became the standard by which we
were competing women against women
then the ioc
said well we're
we're not really
concerned with that
and that's about the time when the the
transgender
uh
community really hadn't uh come along in
force
much before that time there were a few
that were making some
inroads with other sports so i think the
ioc made this
uh change from the chromosome testing to
if you are going to compete as a woman
then you need to have surgery you need
to be a woman
well as
time goes on
the transgender community made some more
issues and said well
some of the athletes can't afford that
they are not going to go to that length
so they relax that
and now they are only testing for
testosterone
my feeling is if they have gone that far
in relaxing all of these
these regulations accord to for
transgender
are they now going to relax them further
and say well now you only have to
identify as a woman
that is my concern we in washington
state i'm on the west coast of the
united states and in my state
and in several other states
that is the only criteria that some boys
can compete against girls is say i
identify as a girl
so this is what really concerns me as as
this progresses is that
we are accommodating a very very very
few
to the um
exclusion of of women so what i'm saying
is that we are accommodating the wants
of a few
against the needs of the many
so
as this
begins to be more invasive
women are going to be hurt by this
if if men only have to say they identify
as a woman that gives them perfect
access and the law now is going to
accommodate that
that they have access to locker rooms to
restrooms to any other women's spaces so
this is not just
sports this is across the board in our
on our culture and i am very fearful for
our women
because of this whole
uh
idea that that has come across so uh yes
i i have a lot of of passion about this
whole
uh identity
and this this gender um
i hate to use the word christ but it
unfortunately for the young people it
has become
a craze
uh and i can say a whole lot more about
that as well so if you want to interject
no we're finding you very interesting
and on the show we'd love to hear our
guests talk
judy i'm going to slightly push back on
that so let's take the case of laurel
haber
as far as i know and correct me if i'm
wrong she had to be below a certain
testosterone level
when she competed
then surely isn't that enough doesn't
that put her an equal footing with all
the other athletes and look trans uh
trans right it's activists would say if
she had such an advantage then how come
she she lost in the first round
[Music]
well first of all
um
if we parlay that out
we can say all right if you're going to
go by testosterone are you going to test
everybody for testosterone and given
there are some women
biological women that have a fairly high
testosterone level are you going to keep
them out just because their testosterone
level is slightly higher so this not
only affects them but it affects all the
other women as well
judy sorry to interject that but
actually uh you you say that as a
theoretical actually at these very
olympics that are occurring as we speak
that has happened several women have
been excluded not from weightlifting but
from other competitions precisely
because of that and so it very much
speaks to your point by the way the
point francis is making is very much a
devil's advocate i think we i think it's
also important to get into the fact that
testosterone alone isn't the only thing
that is the difference between men and
women right
absolutely absolutely
um
i i
firmly believe that that god created men
and women there are only two genders and
your gender is assigned at birth you are
either a man or a woman a girl or a boy
so you are given those testosterones and
yes there are some men have higher
estrogen levels some women have higher
testosterone levels this is all part of
being who we are as those individuals so
as you're saying that in it in and of
itself doesn't make you a man or a woman
so um
that point addressed
uh as far as her performance goes
yes she may have had some of these or or
this testosterone level within those
limits but given her age she's 43 years
old
and
it is very very rare
that a woman can compete on that level
at that age
so that is a that is another factor
uh i can't speak to
why she performed and there's a lot of
different factors why she did what she
did uh she's not the only one that uh
to use the the way living expression
bombed out that is she did not make a
lift
there were unfortunately other lifters
very much male very much female that did
the same thing
so
that in and of itself i don't think her
performance really um
uh
speaks to to to that issue well right
you're not comparing like would like the
fact that a 43 year old athlete bombed
out while competing with 25 year olds
isn't this so i guess in a way the fact
that laurel hubbard made it to the
olympics at the age of 43
shows
to some extent the advantage that laurel
hubbard had right and give us give us
some figures because this would be
interesting on on your personal did you
continue to try and compete at by the
time you were you were 43
oh i hung on as long as i could so my
like i said we we started the
our nationals the u.s nationals in 1981.
i had already been lifting 10 years
before that
but i continued to progress i won uh
four national championships uh and then
that's when i started to
to wane that's when my
lifting my best lifting was about 30 my
early 30s maybe
middle 30s and i stride and as we got
more into international competition and
i saw the olympics coming on i said oh
my goodness i gotta try but there was no
way
uh and that's when i started to to
compete uh at 40 on the master's level
and my lifts were nowhere near
uh
by that time what they were at at my
peak in in my 30s
so can you give us the numbers what at
your peak what what would you lift and
and what might you be lifting at 40 odd
oh let's see my best uh snatch was 82
and a half
and kilos and my best clean jerk was
97 and a half heels
as i started to compete on
on the masters level my snatch
on a good day was probably 60.
um clean and jerk maybe
uh
75
right so you know by that time they were
they were definitely coming down and
believe me i i tried my best i trained
and i i
did all that i could to hang on to that
but but scientifically
you do start losing muscle mass
particularly in women
at least by the age of 40.
so to try to keep that level at that age
there have as contrast we have only a
few men
who generally keep their strength later
than women
we have only a few men that have been
able to keep their uh strength up into
their 40s into the 41 42 43 up around
that that age so it's even very
difficult for men
to do that
and and so you what you're saying is
that it's
utterly remarkable that
laurel hubbard could then compete at
that level really particularly if she
was classified as a woman it's unheard
of essentially
i i truly think so i i think that that
it was it is a rarity
hey constantine how are you feeling
good and your mental health i'm from
russia we don't have mental health well
in the civilized world we talk about our
mental health and how we're feeling
about our place in the universe in the
words of my uncle vlad that is why we
will crush you well he's two months away
from a breakdown for the rest of us
there's a number one mental wellness app
called calm that helps you to negotiate
the tricky modern world it's okay to
need help sometimes and calm can provide
support calm has been really useful for
me you can clear your head with guided
daily meditations improve your focus
with calms curated music tracks and
drift off to dreamland with calm's
imaginative sleep stories narrated by
soothing voices like killian murphy and
stephen fry oh killian save me man up
drink vodka feel better if you go to
calm.com trigger you'll get a limited
time offer of 40 percent off a calm
premium subscription which includes
hundreds of hours of programming and new
content is added every week over 1
million people around the world use calm
to take care of their minds yes
trigonometry fans get special limited
time promotion 40 off premium
subscription take advantage of this
amazing offer go to khan.com forward
slash trigger for 40 off unlimited
access to calm entire library that's
com.com forward slash trigger
and
i can't believe i'm going to ask you
this question but i think it's important
why is it so important that we protect
women's sports in your opinion from
transgender athletes from people who
want to compete
i think it's it's important on a couple
levels first of all like i said to to
uh well let me cite for example um a
case going on right now in the united
states two women
who were uh
who are track athletes
they were competing at the high school
level
a transgender uh boy identified as a
woman competed against them
subsequently broke records that they the
events that these women these girls were
competing in
unfortunately because he was competing
as a woman and and uh uh getting ranked
uh first in in these events breaking
these records they lost their their
college scholarships because of this
so this is the ramification
that is happening very in in right now
in our time that and these are not the
only girls that are going to be affected
if they make this rule across the board
that all you have to do is identify as a
girl or as a woman in competing girls
sports
we are going to
really set women's sports back years
because of the lost opportunities that
they are going to have
competing against women on these
higher levels so that's my first concern
my next concern is the message that
these people are giving to the next
generation of not only um
uh sportsmen sports women those women
that want to compete in sports as
athletes and so forth but but these
younger girls in general saying look at
what what these i can do this it's no
big deal i i think i'm a boy
so unfortunately we have made this so
easy
and now unfortunately we are now
even
making this so accessible that when a
youngster and we're talking
uh
four and five years old
if they express any kind of interest in
the opposite gender
then they are
and i will use the word forcibly because
that is exactly what's happening
the doctors the parents the teachers are
obligated
to transition that youngster
as young as possible
that is the biggest mistake we can make
and unfortunately the more the media
plays with all these transgenders and
the more i quote unquote opportunities
they are giving them
they are just encouraging
this whole
transgender
agenda
as soon as possible for these youngsters
and they have no business doing that i
heard one pediatrician say that this is
the worst form of child abuse that he
has ever seen
and
unfortunately it is going that way
we know that
at youngster and i know from my own
experience when i was young
i liked boy things i like to climb trees
i like to ride bikes over bumps i like
to
wrestle i like to do i like to test my
strength
totally unheard of when i've been i was
growing up in the
in the 50s and 60s
that was totally unheard of
did you know
that girls just don't do those things
if i had been
later doing those things later as a girl
they
more than likely they would have said oh
you should have been a boy let's
transition you like these things i said
oh yes i want to be a boy because that's
and i thought that would be great
but i grew out of that and that's what
they're saying with these youngsters is
that
the greater percentage is up into the
almost the 90 percent
that these children grow out of it
so as we we transition these youngsters
into this
we are forcing them into this whole area
that they should never have been entered
into uh by the time they get into
puberty and we've given them puberty
blockers and we have told them to to
transition into that opposite gender
they are very very confused
we are seeing uh suicide rates
unbelievable uh in these and the
argument i will say is that well
uh
my my son or daughter had threatened
suicide like my son did
he threatened suicide
but my point is yes there is a dis
dysphoria between the mind and the body
but my point is
can we not try to get the mind in line
with the body rather than going through
all of this
mutilation of the body to bring it in
line with the mind
i think not
god created you as a man or as a woman
and he has given you a mind as a man
a mind as a woman
and your body is is
in line with that
unfortunately we have now made
conversion therapy illegal
and that bothers me a lot
that even if a a person
uh
says oh maybe i'm not sure
oh no no can't do that it is illegal for
a pastor for a parent for a any
professional health care
illegal for a teacher to encourage any
conversion therapy that is
to say that
if you're questioning
your your gender and you think well
maybe i'm not maybe i i really should
i'm really not a a boy like i thought it
was i really am a girl
nope you're no you you're we're
transitioning you into a boy
what situation does this put the child
in uh judy this is something we've
covered on the show uh quite a bit but
uh just coming back to sport because i
do want to uh bring up the the the
the suicide and all of that side of it
because i do think it's a big part of
the conversation just coming back to the
sport for a moment some people might say
uh
the counter argument to many of the
things you're saying is well look you
were a pioneer in in in in women's
sports and you would be turning up to
gyms i imagine and feeling like there's
no place for you there and you didn't
quite fit in and if it weren't for your
husband who was supporting and
encouraging you uh you really would have
been an outcast and an outlier in that
environment and you had to fight and
fight and fight to be given the
opportunity to be included to be
represented to be seen you had to work
with other people like you other women
to get the chance to compete surely you
can emphasize with someone these people
would argue
you can emphasize with someone who
currently feels like they're being
excluded they are not able to compete
they don't have the opportunity
to perform at the olympics
in the gender identity that they very
strongly feel that they are
uh well
i i feel that
i
i obeyed the rules as it were the rule
stated that
weightlifting was for men that's fine
i competed outside of the competition
until
we could get women against women i think
this is a whole different avenue because
it carries so much more of the
ramifications and
they do have their own games they have
the gay
games they which includes the lgbtq
community so in that respect they say
okay well we have
and and and to answer your question they
have gone to
like people
they have garnered their group and they
have formed their
their competitions against who they are
but when it comes to the olympics the
olympics is exclusionary between men and
women
that is the point that i the the
olympics is a a
to me a very sacred ground it has been
for years and years so unfortunately
when you start
going down this road
that's what i'm i'm saying is that you
may be exclu
just like uh laurel
what what women did she
step over as it were
to get to that position there were many
women that fought very very hard to get
to that olympic podium to get to that
olympic stage
and they weren't allowed to do that
because of what she did so i'm i'm
that's where i'm coming from in women's
sports let women compete against women
because if we don't then you're opening
up a whole new can of worms and these
women what are they going to say
it might really come down to the point
to where
their the women are being frustrated and
said what's the use
if that guy says that he's a girl i have
no chance so why
so uh we're putting this
in that sort of vein
and i am very concerned that we're
opening up this very big
uh can of worms as it were uh when it
comes to women competing um on these on
these higher levels
uh certainly on the on the lower level
like i mentioned uh on these states that
they just say that you can just say
you're you're a girl and
have at it and these girls that have
striven so hard they have trained so
hard
they miss their opportunities and judy
what is the attitude towards these
transgender athletes amongst female
athletes i'm not really sure i
to to be real honest i haven't had the
opportunity to really
uh question them um i will say
kind of on that on that vein they did a
uh gender testing was done up until
about
1998 with the with the chromosomes
then uh uh there was kind of an uproar
saying oh well these these women feel
violated and they feel like they're
being uh
in in intruded upon their they're
questioning my my gender
however they sent a questionnaire to 3
000 athletes
asking them two questions number one do
you feel violated by uh questioning your
gender and number two would you like
this to continue
they got out of that
over three thousand they got almost a
thousand responses back the overwhelming
response over 80 to 85 percent said
yes we want this to continue
and 90 over 90 percent said i do not
feel violated
so from that i and and grant this was
years ago
but i still feel that that probably
would be the same
um
the same today that that women would
want that same thing they want to be be
equal on that footing
and judy do you think laurel hubbard
marks the start of a pattern where we're
going to start to see more and more
transgender athletes competing in elite
sport elite female sport
we could it all depends on the ilc
if they continue to
uh relax the
the criteria then i i think it will uh
and not only in our yes i i think across
the board in in olympic sports
uh the door is the door is definitely
open and i think there are many that
will
will go through that door judy let me
ask you another stupid question i know
we're asking you quite a lot of them but
but it's because we live in a society
where we pretend that we don't know the
answer to them so let me do this uh can
you give us first of all just some
figures for the differences between
elite male weight lifters and elite
female weight lifters competing in the
same
in the same competitions for the same
movements what kind of differences are
we seeing
no uh weight wise uh weights lifted are
you talking about
um
well for example we just watched the the
super heavyweights
and uh lasha uh lifted 585
uh pounds i forget the kilos 200 and
some odd kilos i'm sorry uh we're so
used to pounds over here not naturally
but
an enormous amount of weight
super heavy weight
and our
uh the the
uh super heavy weight in the women
lifted
close to 400 pounds i do believe
um so you know there's
there's a big big gap um and what if
that male lifter was to take some kind
of testosterone suppressants or
something to lower their testosterone
would that immediately make them into uh
would that reduce their performance to
women's levels
i can't say that it that it actually
would because there you know there's
there's so many other factors other than
that so
i hesitate to say yes or no on on that
particular i would say just off the top
of my head that yeah testosterone makes
it makes a difference um
that's pretty much
why men have testosterone and can do the
things they do and women have a lower
testosterone than higher estrogen but
what i'm getting at is there are other
physiological differences between men
and women on the the the shape of the
hips the angle of the legs and the size
of the heart the lungs the the all sorts
of other stuff
absolutely so
what i'm asking you really is it's just
dropping you've taken a male elite
weight lifter and reducing their level
of testosterone is that enough to make
them be able to compete with women who
have the same level of testosterone as
they do
i
i wouldn't say that it would
um and and the other thing is that that
the muscle physiology of a man is is
different they retain a lot more of that
that testosterone and it
uh so and i am not a doctor i am not a
you know i but from my background uh in
sports and and the studies i have
there is a a vast difference between the
physiology of uh men and women's muscle
for example so
the tendon strength the attachment
strength uh like i said the retention of
of testosterone all of these make it
make a difference so it's not just that
one factor
that i that i think uh
would would make the difference
and judy do you think this is this whole
saga has been damaging for women's
weightlifting
i don't know if it's been actually
damaging
um it might make the women
uh more competitive and say hey you know
we want to
compete as women so it could kind of go
either way i i don't think one woman
or one man transgendering is going to
make a
great deal of difference at this point
however i do feel as we have mentioned
that it does open the door uh for others
to to come in
so to make a difference in in women's
weightlifting at this point
uh i'm not sure that it will but i i do
think that it will in in in future
uh generations
it sounds like your concern is the
regulations uh
making sure that the regulations are
fair uh
and i guess if if you don't think that
testosterone alone is a measure of of
that then the fact that that is the
criteria that's currently criterion has
currently been used then i imagine you
don't feel the current rules are
appropriate
i don't think so but unfortunately
as they say the genie is out of the
bottle uh i i would like to go back to
to chromosome testing however that's
probably not going to happen why not
history has shown that that regulations
generally do not backtrack they only get
softer they don't get harder
so that's that is my biggest concern is
the track record like i say you follow
what the ioc has done in the past
they've gotten softer they haven't
gotten harder so to go back to that and
you we have now such a a
a big uh transgender voice not just in
the athletic arena but and this is
interesting too as kind of a side mark
that um
most of the people pushing for a lot of
the transgender activity are not
transgenders they are political people
who are pushing this
transgender agenda
so
uh i that's why i think that that the
rules aren't going to go back to that
because we have such a major
uh political group that will get
involved and and and fight for
uh less not more
judy why do you think this case has
struck such a chord because you know
women's power lifters
women's power lifting weightlifting it's
a minority sport you know it will have
its people who will follow who will
enjoy it but it's not a mainstream sport
there i say
but this case has elevated it to a
mainstream sport to a mainstream story
it's been talked all over the world
why do you think that is
because
naturally because uh
as you said
weightlifting has been primarily a man's
sport
um
so
and and strength
has been particularly
the i i would say the the mirror of
a man's strength or a woman's strength
so
this is kind of been the determination
uh this is weightlifting is the epitome
of strength
so you have someone coming in as as this
person and and naturally it's going to
be uh
the
the uh the forefront of what a man or a
woman is
um
so i i think that that in and of itself
is is going to be the the pivot point
of this this whole transgender thing is
is watching what
women do with strength and what men do
with strength
and judy if you don't mind me asking
about your personal story with your
family because i do think it's relevant
here if that's okay with you
how do you how do you square your very
passionate defense of
protecting women's sport with your own
experience where uh which you've written
about in in your book uh of having a a
son who who was not comfortable with
with his sex or his gender uh wanted to
to transition was unable to and
eventually ended up sadly taking his own
life
i'm sure for a mother that's literally
the worst thing that could happen and of
course our heart goes out to you but but
how do you how do you reconcile those
two things because i imagine you would
have wanted your son to get whatever
support he needed to to be happy and to
live a happy life
therein lies the rub
i knew that
he was not a woman
and to
allow him to pursue that avenue would
only lead to his unhappiness this is not
it has shown time and time again
that the surgeries the
the transitioning does not solve the
problem the suicide rates after
transition are just as high it does not
solve anything so when it came to my son
we really
tried and we prayed diligently that
that he would get the help uh through
counseling through um
whatever means we could to again
show him that he truly was god gave him
a a male body and he had a plan for him
as a boy growing up into a man
and this is very unfortunate because
like i said as we push these people into
it
there they find that many times this is
not the solution
so
i that's why we didn't did not uh
go along we did not condone him
we we made sure that he understood we
love him
we loved him as our child no matter what
he is and when no matter what he does he
is always our child we love him but
unfortunately we couldn't condone
that that journey that he was taking
because in our hearts we knew
it would only lead to unhappiness i have
talked to many people
who have come out of their transition
and said
this is this was the body that god gave
me this is where i am going to find
peace and happiness it was not in
that that opposite gender
so
that's why i'm pushing so hard to
[Music]
get conversion therapy allowed so that
we can get these people
on the right track so that they have
their mind and their body in in sync and
not try to go through
something that is going to be
irreversible uh
in their in their bodies
so
the the whole idea of of pushing these
these people are
are doing them i think a a disservice
hey constantin are you crypto curious i
told you this sort of behavior is
illegal in my country if you've thought
about entering the world of
cryptocurrency but it felt a little too
overwhelmed coinbase makes learning to
buy and sell simple coinbase is a
trusted and easy to use platform to buy
sell and spend cryptocurrencies
they support the most popular digital
currencies on the market and make them
accessible to everyone in russia we have
sputnik coin it will take you to the
moon but you might not come back okay
mate cryptocurrency might feel like a
secret or exclusive club but coinbase
believes that everyone everywhere should
be able to get in the door whether
you've been trading for years or just
getting started coinbase can help real
men don't ask for help and by real men i
mean russians
great coinbase offer portfolio
management and protection learning
resources and a mobile app so you can
trade securely and monitor your crypto
all in one place whether you're looking
to diversify just getting started or
searching for a better way to access
crypto markets start today with coinbase
for a limited time new users can get
five euros in free bitcoin when you sign
up today at coinbase.com
forward slash trigger sign up at
coinbase.com forward slash trigger for
five euros in free bitcoin this offer is
for a limited time only so be sure to
sign up today that's coinbase.com
forward slash trigger if you're a real
man
so when you say conversion therapy the
only time i've ever heard conversion
therapy judy is gay conversion therapy
which we know just doesn't work how is
transgender conversion therapy different
and how does it work
well my my take on conversion therapy as
as we're using it is to allow that
person to at least consider
that they are not of the opposite gender
and uh unfortunately many times they are
convinced
that and there's no talking to them but
but there are some
that i and i'm talking about children
of young children who exhibit the
opposite gender behavior
and later on and they parents or
teachers or whoever have allowed them to
uh display the opposite gender behavior
as much as they want to but later on
they say hmm
maybe i maybe i do really like to put on
a dress
and they were born a girl and maybe they
thought they were a boy so they played
with boys things and so on and so forth
but later on
maybe i do like to put on a dress or
maybe i
i do like
a girl thing
today's
society
will have already put them on the path
to being a boy with no turning around
so my conversion therapy is saying let's
allow that child
to
at least
be themselves and explore
what their what their birth gender
really is and be
at
uh at peace with that be happy with that
and whatever way we can we can allow
them to do that through counseling
uh
through primarily through through
counseling but uh
that's that's my point on on conversion
at least letting them
uh explore what they're
where they're happy in and possibly
their birth gender no it sounds like
what you're really talking about is
you're against the transitioning of
children
which i think most people would be
absolutely
there have been again many many studies
showing that
these these kids who are put on
that transgender path that early
by the time they get into into puberty
you can imagine how confused how
frustrating they might be
they are
puberty blockers which means that that
everything is stopped their hormones
have stopped their bodies are not
developing like they should have so they
see their peers going through this
stage
and they're doing nothing
uh
the girls are not developing breasts
they're not going through their periods
and so forth the guys are not developing
beards and and so forth so there's
they're in a quandary well
who am i i don't see anything happening
so they're identifying really as as
neither because they don't see any
progress in what they're going through
unfortunately again
this can be irreversible
so perchance they do go
later on in life and say
i really was a woman i'm not a man i've
talked with several people who have
lived in the opposite gender
uh females particularly living as a man
for maybe 15 20 years
and they
they come to themselves
and they say
god put me in a woman's body i am a
woman
now if they had gone through all the
surgery
they are
uh
they they have irreversible damage
they have lost their their uh
sex drive and organs and and their uh
hormones and so forth so
unfortunately damage done
that's my concern when we have all these
kids going through this and
unfortunately it has become a fad
uh
because we are introducing it so early
in our sex education courses that
they're they are literally taught to
explore who they really are they are not
we have taken out pink and blues we have
taken out girls and boys
everybody is just one neutral person
so right off the bat our kids are being
told you can be anything that you want
to be
so
our kids are are unfortunately being
used as i think pawns uh in this whole
situation
they are truly not allowed to really um
go the path that that they were
they were created to be
judy thank you so much for coming on the
show
we're going to ask a few questions for
our local supporters afterwards but
we're going to end this interview with
our final question which is always
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society but we really should
be
i think we've pretty much covered the
waterfront uh as far as that goes um
that i think that that i
i would encourage any parent
who is involved with their a transgender
son or daughter to really
um explore really what what transgender
is uh and
go into the research go into the
background find out really what is
happening before you allow your child
really to get into this uh
god has a plan for for them in the
gender that that they were given and
that's the only way that they can find
fulfillment and happiness uh in in that
place that that god has for them
thanks judy and uh before we ask our
locals questions and before we let you
go for the purposes of the interview uh
where can people find your work online
my
uh book mom i'm a girl is at
judyglenny.com
[Music]
uh my weightlifting book uh uplifting
dreams is at w l
g l e n n e y w l
glenny.com so both of those books are
available on on my two websites
judy thanks for coming on the show and
thank you all for watching at home we
will see you very soon with another
episode like this one or raw show all
them go out at 7pm uk time which is 2
p.m eastern take care and see you soon
guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below